comenzó ya formalmente el proceso para
elegir candidato presidencial de la
oposición para 2024 como la ley no
permite a los partidos hablar de
precandidaturas así como en morena
decidieron Llamar a su eventual
candidato como coordinador Nacional para
la defensa de la transformación en la
oposición han decidido llamarlo
responsable Nacional para la
construcción del frente amplio opositor
Por México este proceso consta de tres
etapas en la oposición la primera es el
registro de los aspirantes que ha
comenzado ya este día quien logre reunir
150.000 firmas en 17 estados de la
república pasará a una segunda etapa en
la que se aplicará una encuesta para
determinar a los tres perfiles más
populares también habrá un foro Nacional
de discusión los que resulten los tres
más populares pasarán a una tercera y
última etapa que consiste en cinco foros
regionales de debate y una última
encuesta para ver quién de los tres es
el más popular a la par se hará una
consulta directa a la ciudadanía el 3 de
septiembre de forma tal que quien gane
Esta última encuesta y quien sea elegido
por la ciudadanía en esta consulta será
el candidato presidencial de la
oposición en este día de comienzo de los
registros acudieron por parte del pan
del partido Acción Nacional el diputado
Santiago krill y La senadora Xóchitl
Gálvez posteriormente lo harán los
aspirantes de los otros partidos del
frente el pri Y el PRD el presidente
López Obrador ha descalificado este
proceso ha dicho que se trata de una
simulación y que los oligarcas han
decidido a quien imponer que se trata de
xochitl Gálvez en respuesta a la
senadora ha dicho que ese es un
comentario machista de quien piensa que
una mujer por sus propios méritos no
puede tener una candidatura presidencial
así los ánimos ya rumbo a 2024